this is breaking news
on 8 news now good evening we are
tracking breaking news coming out of
north las vegas tonight
a homicide investigation is currently
underway right at
revere and brooks that is near cheyenne
and mlk
police are on scene in that area and so
is orco mana orca what is the very
latest
[Music]
well denise and brian we actually just
learned more
details from police in just the past
couple of minutes
we've learned that this is a shooting
and the person who died is a man in his
30s now this is the scene back here
behind me
there's still a handful of north las
vegas police officers and detectives out
here at this hour
we're told it happened around 2 30 this
afternoon but right now
we are still trying to get more details
in addition to those
preliminary details that we just got
just moments ago i can tell you that
detectives seem to be focusing their
investigation
on a dirt area back there off of brooks
avenue which again is near cheyenne and
mlk but again the latest details that we
have from north las vegas police
this is a deadly shooting the person who
died
a man in his 30s we of course are going
to learn more from police hopefully in
the next few hours and we will be sure
to update you
both on air and online reporting live
from north las vegas tonight orco mana 8
news now